bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
vincent biruta c'est le ministre des
affaires étrangères du rwanda il est
avec nous depuis la capitale rwandaise
kigali monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup
merci à vous monsieur le ministre la
situation est à nouveau explosive entre
votre pays et la république démocratique
du congo dans l'est de la rdc ce
vendredi il ya eu un incident grave à la
frontière à goma la capitale du nord
kivu un soldat congolais seraient entrés
en territoire rwandais et il a été
abattu par les forces rwandaises est-ce
que vous confirmer cette information et
s'agite il selon vous d'un incident
isolé ou des prémices d'un possible
affrontement entre vos deux pays
je confirme l'incident soldats congolais
a traversé la frontière et a tiré sur le
policier tiré de la frontière et des
policiers pour un d'identité wc c'est
après cela que
les policiers ont réagi et ont bâti le
soldat congolais
sur cet incident survient dans un
contexte un contexte où il ya eu des
discours deviennent des incitations à la
violence le côté démocratique du congo
et donc c'était sida est à placer dans
son contexte c'est pas un incident qu'on
peut qualifier d qualifié d' incident
isolé parce que il est isolé dans un
contexte déterminé
pour moi c'est comment se crée c'est
comme ça que j'étais un peu de ciment
est ce que vous pensez que cette
personne a agi par elle même ou est ce
que l ai incités par les autorités
militaires congolaises a peut-être tenté
certaines opérations ou peut-être vous
provoquer
ça je ne peux pas le dire parce que il
va y avoir des enquêtes où on va on doit
savoir exactement ce qui s'est passé on
va voir 220 si ça faisait partie des
blancs mais c'est un conte initiatique
tout seul mais sans l'atteindre
c'est inquiète vous avez échangé ce
vendredi avec votre homologue congolais
christopher lutundula ce propos et a
plus généralement sur la situation
volatile entre vos deux pays
on a échangé essentiellement sur les sea
dogs de ce matin et je n'y ai visionné
près de ce qui s'était passé était déjà
en courant et la halle aux blés télé
sida et
cgd inquiété de savoir ce qui s'est
exactement passé
alors la république démocratique du
congo a suspendu tous les accords et pré
accord signé avec le rwanda évidemment
on se demande quelle sera la prochaine
étape est ce que votre ambassadeur à
kinshasa pour être expulsé et est-ce
qu'on pourra aller jusqu'à une rupture
des relations diplomatiques entre vos
deux pays
ça c'est une question qu'il faut poser
la partie congolaise qui a plus une
initiative de seconde que ces accords ça
donnait des détails et ceci doit suivre
c'est c'est vraiment qu'on voulait
qu'ils devraient recevoir les idées qui
peut prendre à ce qui concerne les
relations diplomatiques en ce qui
concerne la présence d'une trappe assad
qui chassa ça c'est vraiment qu'on est
ici dont il est
question mais alors je vous posais une
question qui vous concerne vous
directement est-ce que vous de votre
côté vous pourriez prendre une telle
initiative de rupture des relations
diplomatiques en raison des tensions en
raison de la suspension de ces accords
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
sur la table pour le rwanda
nous ferons s'inscrit dans une logique
de recherche d'une solution en face et
chic c'est déchirant et il ya des
mécanismes régionaux qui sont en place
pour résoudre les problèmes de sécurité
à l'essai de la révolte côté du congo
c'est dans cette logique que nous nous
inscrivons et donc arte nous concerne
nous n'avons plus aucune décision allant
dans le sens de rompre nos relations
diplomatiques et
je ne crois pas que une initiative vient
de notre côté alors justement à propos
des initiatives régionales le président
du kenya uhuru kenyatta a appelé ce
mercredi dans un communiqué je le cite
au déploiement immédiat d'une force
régionale dans l'est de la rdc une
réunion opératoire doit se tenir ce
dimanche est ce que vous y être
favorables et évidemment est ce que le
rwanda pourrait participer à une telle
initiative étant donné les tensions dont
on vient de parler
nous sommes favorables à l'initiative de
la mesure où il s'inscrit dans la nuit
dans la lignée des décisions qui ont été
prises par les chefs d'état d'un
réunion du 21 avril anaérobie est donc
levé été décidés à tenter de mettre en
place d' ado mettre
en route un processus politique en ce
qui concerne les groupes armés congolais
et processus de désarmement de
désarmement de la particiation en ce qui
concerne les confirmés étrangers basés à
laisser derrière nous côté du couvent où
il avait été aussi décidé de mettre en
place une force militaire pour
combattre les besoins et inertie de
téléphone de blida dans la ligne tracée
par les chefs d'état et donc nouvelle
marrant des soutiens la décision et
laurent d'être est évidement à envoyer
des hommes j'ai pas de cette force
régionale donc tout sur la fin de
l'année des décisions déjà prises d'eau
concorde en aérobie
vif et on a été présent et et nous
présenter et nous sommes disposés aussi
de notre contribution à toute solution
et conflits la passivité
de la partie militaire on sait que la
rdc vous demande de retirer vos troupes
sur le territoire congolais l'ambassade
des états unis en rdc s'est dit je le
cite préoccupé par la présence signalée
de forces rwandaises sur le territoire
de la rdc si vos alliés américains le
disent c'est que ça doit être vrai vous
avez des soldats en ce moment sur le sol
de la rdc
gouvernement du rwanda a fait toutes les
mesures pour protéger son territoire et
ses citoyens contre les menaces de
sécurité mais nous n'avons pas de soldat
allez-vous démocratique du congo
aujourd'hui souci a été déterrée par
l'ambassade américaine et de présence
est signalée
c'est une présence confirmée mais je
dois que nous avons en classe de la
région des mécanismes d'éducation
utilisons censé fed est inquiète et
surtout les étudiants y compris des
incidents transfrontaliers et donc il
n'appartient pas à
chacun at il déclaré
gds innovation ou bien deux
des illustrations mais présence signalée
et il ya des mécanismes en place tout ce
que le gouvernement d achat et neutre
asin à l'avenue ses dauphins des mesures
nécessaires protéger son territoire et
ses sites et le m23 la commission des
affaires étrangères du sénat américain
parle du soutien rwandais aux rebelles
du m23 on sait que vous le nier mais de
nombreux observateurs pensent que le m23
agit à travers votre aide notamment
financière et militaire vous continuez à
le nier
ceci est ailier design c'est l idéologie
qui se vide à la région en inde m 23
degrés bien s'essayer avec le rwanda
parce que c'est des cons bullet in one
off et ce sont des congolais donc cette
idéologie qui s'est propagée vers la
région a pâti des années 90 et qu'il
saurait des congolais qui ne sont pas
des villes table comme ou les et ça
continue à se propager et nîmes la force
des nations unies et qui est amené à
décider assez compact vous former et les
manifester du zèle quand il s'agit de
combattre aux particuliers notamment de
rénover trois mais ils fassent la fosse
face plusieurs années des dizaines
d'années à ne rien faire contre d'autres
groupes armés qui sont bien connues
aussi bas au niveau des nations unies
notamment aux fdlr c'est une force qui
est liée au
génocide au rwanda de 1994
et sinon les relations
avaient très
mal et il y en a pas très rapidement
monsieur biruta le partenariat
migratoire avec le royaume uni fait
couler beaucoup d'encre un premier avion
a été stoppé à l'ultime minute par un
recours est ce que vous êtes prêts à
changer d'avis ou est-ce que vous allez
en effet accueillir ces réfugiés que le
royaume uni va vous envoyer par charter
nous nous sommes engagés
qui concerne
l'accord que nous avons signé avec le
royaume uni et ses locaux en justice
était prévu on savait d'être au pouvoir
réguler et nous sommes disposés ne sont
prêts à recevoir ces migrants
dès que les mini est prêt à les emmener
chez nous commençâmes d'exposer nous
sommes prêts à aller devant tout ce
qu'il faut en place pour des raisons
voir aussitôt que nous pouvons être
andré ici
monsieur le ministre on se souvient
qu'il y avait eu un accord similaire un
petit peu avec israël il ya quelques
années mais face
aux critiques face aux pressions
finalement cet accord n'avait pas été
mise en place est ce que vous pensez que
la même chose pourrait arriver à cet
accord avec la grande bretagne qui est
en effet très critiquée
ce sont des accords différents l'accord
que nous avons signé avec l'oreille aux
mines et tout un problème c'est tout un
programme de
200 g de continuer une solution à la
migration illégale et nous sommes
ensemble nous avons se voir ces gens
nous allons leur donner les compétences
pour qu'ils puissent être économiquement
et aider soit ici soit dans un autre
pays d'accueil soit dans mon pays
d'origine s'il décide de rentrer et nous
devons continuer à les solutions et nous
sommes disposés à marcher vous n'êtes
que tous les autres aussi qui sont
concernés coco laboy et si ça marche
tant mieux si ça ne marche pas on aura
donné on a proposé au moins une solution
parce que ceux qui s'opposent à ce
programme ceux qui s'opposent à cet
accord il faut se poser mais ne propose
aucune solution à la question des
migrations illégales et au réseau de
trafiquants d'être humains il s'utilise
aussi qu'ils collectent de l'argent pour
aider ces gens à rejoindre la grande
bretagne d'autres pays
enfin votre donc ça c'était un grand
problème on va rester réussir à voir les
gens sont noyés en mer méditerranée
chaque année puis
en ce qui concerne l est ce qu'ils
trouvaient ce côté de l'afrique nous
avons voulu continuer à une solution à
son problème
si ça marche tant mieux si on est
disposé aussi à assurer la mise en
oeuvre a fait des ajustements
nécessaires mais nous on est disposé à
jouer notre rôle à la mise à l'eau cet
accord vincent biruta ministre des
affaires étrangères du rwanda merci à
vous d'avoir été avec nous depuis kigali
et merci à vous d'avoir suivi cet
entretien sur nos antennes
[Musique]